der Bundeskanzler zwar im
Bundeskanzleramt ist aber nicht im
ersten Stock sondern wie ich sehe im
achten Stock in der sogenannten
kanzler-wohnung sie sehen auch es gibt
sie wirklich es gab ja das eine oder
andere Gerücht dass es sie gar nicht
gäbe das sehen Sie jetzt ich darf
herzlich begrüßen außerdem den
Vizekanzler Robert Habeck und den
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
zu einer Pressekonferenz so die wir eben
eingeladen haben und ich würde
vorschlagen der Bundeskanzler beginnt
dann Herr Habeck dann Herr Lindner und
dann zu ihren Fragen bitte sehr
meine Damen und Herren Russland setzt
sein
en brutalen Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine unverändert fort
aber Russland setzt nicht nur im Krieg
Waffen ein sondern setzt auch
international seine Energielieferung als
Waffe ein
deshalb können wir spätestens nach den
Zerstörungen an den Pipelines den
Gaspipelines in der Ostsee sagen auf
absehbare Zeit wird Gas aus Russland
nicht mehr geliefert werden
wir sind allerdings auf diese Situation
gut vorbereitet wir haben Entscheidungen
getroffen die es uns ermöglichen mit
dieser veränderten Situation umzugehen
Deutschland importiert Gas von anderen
Ländern wir nutzen die Kapazitäten der
westeuropäischen Hilfen der Niederlande
Belgiens und Frankreichs wir waren
Flüssiggas Terminals an den
norddeutschen Küsten unsere Speicher
sind zu über 90% gefüllt die
Kohlekraftwerke werden wieder in Betrieb
genommen und viele sind es bereits wir
nutzen die Kapazitäten der
deutschen Atomkraftwerke in den Monaten
Januar Februar März April wenn das
notwendig ist und wir werden alles dafür
tun dass wir auch unsere Speicher nutzen
dann für den Winter so dass die Lage
entspannt werden kann und wir eine gute
Versorgung haben
aber klar das führt trotzdem dazu dass
die Preise hoch sind und damit sind
viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger aber viele
Unternehmen unseren blonde für eine
große Herausforderung gestellt die sich
nicht einfach bewältigen lässt die
Preise müssen runter das ist unser ganz
entscheidender Überzeugung dafür wird
die Bundesregierung alles tun damit die
Preise sinken spannen wir jetzt einen
großen apfelschirm ein Abwehrschirm der
dazu beitragen soll dass die Rentner und
Rentner in unserem Land dass die
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitnehmer die
Familien auf dem Lande und in der Stadt
dass die Singles das die Verkäuferinnen
und Verkäufer das alle gut zurechtkommen
können und dass sie die Preise bezahlen
können aber auch der Bäckermeister um
die Ecke die Handwerkerin oder die
großen Industriebetriebe die auf Strom
und gastlieferungen angewiesen sind die
jetzt viel zu teuer sind
dieser Abwehrschirm wird gespeist aus
dem neu dazu benutzen Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds den wir mit 200
Milliarden Euro ausstatten werden diese
200 Milliarden Euro werden wir durch
eine Kreditaufnahme finanzieren und
damit in der Lage sein in diesem Jahr im
nächsten Jahr und dem übernächsten Jahr
die Aufgaben zu bewältigen jetzt vor uns
stehen
eine Maßnahme zur Senkung der Preise
haben wir bereits auf den Weg gebracht
und es wird jetzt einfacher das ist die
strompreisbremse sie wird gerade
vorbereitet jetzt geht es um eine
gaspreisbremse dazu haben wir eine
Kommission eingesetzt die ganz konkrete
Vorschläge in kürzester Zeit machen wird
aber was jetzt möglich ist ist dass sie
die Mittel einsetzen kann damit die
Preise sinken für die Verbrauchern
Verbraucher überall im Land für die
Familien für die Rentner und Rentner für
die Handwerk und Handwerker aber eben
auch für die Unternehmen die kleinen und
großen und das ist auch dringend
notwendig damit wir durch diese
schwierige Zeit kommen mit den 200
Milliarden Euro haben wir die
Möglichkeiten das alles zu finanzieren
und dazu beizutragen dass das
funktioniert
klar das versetzt uns auch in die Lage
auf die unter anderem Umständen auch als
es noch Gaslieferung aus Russland gab
geplante gasumlage zu verzichten sie
wird nicht mehr gebraucht wir werden die
Unternehmen da geht es vor allem um drei
direkt unterstützen so dass das nicht zu
einer Mehrbelastung der Verbrauchern
Verbrauchern viele andere Unternehmen
führt aber diese Unternehmen trotzdem
wirtschaftlich durch diese Situation
kommen können und ihre Aufgabe für die
Gasversorgung Deutschlands auch weiter
wahrnehmen können
das alles zusammen sind weitreichende
Entlastungsmaßnahmen die dann noch
ergänzt werden durch ganz konkrete
Hilfen für Unternehmen die nicht bereits
durch die Entlastung bei den Preisen
besser durch die Lage kommen als das
heute der Fall ist für uns ist ganz klar
das ist eine Aufgabe die das ganze Land
gemeinsam schultern muss wir müssen uns
unterhaken und wir können uns auch
unterhaken wir haben eine
leistungsfähige Volkswirtschaft wir
haben stabile Staatsfinanzen auch durch
die sehr sorgfältige Politik der letzten
Jahre und die die wir in den nächsten
Jahren planen indem wir dafür sorgen
dass wir immer so gut wie möglich mit
den Vorgaben unserer Verfassung umgehend
dafür sorgen dass wir gute aufgestellte
Haushalte haben aber jetzt schaffen wir
die Kraft mit dem Abwehrschirm das zu
tun damit Strompreise damit Gaspreise
sinken dramatisch sinken und damit sie
von den Bürgern und Bürgern und den
Unternehmen bewältigt werden können das
ist die Aufgabe jetzt haben und diese
Aufgabe Schultern wir auch ich habe aber
andere Gelegenheit gesagt die Maßnahmen
die wir ergreifen sind ein Bums man kann
sagen dass es hier ein doppelbums es
soll dazu beitragen dass jetzt schnell
zügig und für alle schnell feststellbar
die Preise sinken für Energie so dass
sich niemand Sorgen machen muss wenn er
an den Herbst und den Winter denkt wenn
er an Weihnachten denkt und dann das
nächste Jahr und dann die Rechnung auch
die hohen Rechnungen die einige jetzt
bereits bekommen haben als
Abschlagszahlung werden sich dann wieder
reduzieren können das ist das konkrete
ziel der Maßnahme unter Förderung die
wir uns vorgenommen haben
meine Damen und Herren der russische
Krieg gegen die Ukraine geht unverändert
weiter und er nimmt dann Brutalität und
härtet zu wir sehen das jeden Tag
trotzdem sind wir überzeugt dass die
Ukrainer und Ukraine in der Lage sein
werden die Integrität und Souveränität
ihres Landes zu verteidigen auch weil
sie sich darauf verlassen können dass
die Weltgemeinschaft nicht einfach
zuschauen wenn ein großer mächtiger
Nachbar
ein anderes Land überfällt und wir
werden unsere Solidarität fortsetzen
aber wir sind auch in der Lage dafür zu
sorgen dass unser Land das
wirtschaftlich stark ist eine so große
Herausforderung bewältigen kann dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihr Leben führen
können dass die Preise für Energie nicht
durch die Decke schießen sondern dass
sie für Sie alle bewältigbar sind und
für die Unternehmen die für unsere
Arbeitsplätze wichtig sind auch schönen
Dank
vielen Dank als nächstes Robert Habeck
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die Energiekrise die wir in
Europa erleben droht sich zu einer
Wirtschafts- und auch einer sozialen
Krise auszuwachsen mit der Entscheidung
die wir heute vorstellen
unterbinden wir das halten wir gegen wie
der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat das ist
eine große Entscheidung 200 Milliarden
für einen Abwehrschirm der dann
verausgabt über den Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds tatsächlich
abwehren soll tatsächlich den Angriff
von Russland von Putins Regime auf
unsere Volkswirtschaft und über eine
Destabilisierung unserer Volkswirtschaft
eine Destabilisierung der demokratischen
Ordnung in Europa und in Deutschland zu
erreichen das ist die Macht die wir
Putin gegeben haben durch eine zu große
Abhängigkeit von Gas und das ist die
Gegenwehr heute mit dem Abwehrschirm die
wir ergreifen und diese Macht zu brechen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ist ein
großer und ein bedeutender Schritt es
ist aber auch einer der in seiner
Pauschalität und in seiner massiven
Wirkung für die Alternativen die wir
sonst gearbeitet haben eine deutliche
Verbesserung darstellt er ist pauschaler
er ist einfacher und er ist schneller
das ist nur möglich weil er ein so
großes Volumen stellt und ich möchte
mich beim Finanzminister bei Christian
Lindner bedanken dass dieses große
Volumen erbracht werden konnte
dieser Schritt ist eben auch eine
Maßnahme die Unterstützung für die
Bevölkerung und für die Unternehmen
bürokratiearm zu gestalten weil wir den
Preis insgesamt jetzt im Gasbereich und
parallel dazu im Strombereich senken und
decken
wir bringen und das sage ich als
Wirtschaftsminister wir bringen eine
enorme finanzielle Kraft auf um die
Zukunftsfähigkeit und die
Investitionsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft zu schützen und zu erhalten
das ist wichtig und notwendig es geht
nicht nur darum irgendwie durch diese
Krise durchzukommen sondern als starke
robuste Volkswirtschaft diese Zeit zu
bestehen um dann in der Zukunft die
weiteren Aufgaben die uns
gesellschaftlich gestellt sind zu
bestehen
mit der Abschaffung der gasumlage wird
ebenfalls Bürokratie reduziert die
Gasanlage war ein Instrument um die
Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland zu
gewähren sie hat ja den Verlust von
Energie bei gleichlaufenden Verträgen
der großen Unternehmen kompensieren
sollen
sie war ein wichtiges Instrument für die
Versorgungssicherheit jetzt gibt es
andere Instrumente das finanzielle
Volumen das jetzt geschaffen wurde stand
vor einigen Wochen oder Monaten doch
nicht zur Verfügung insofern ist es
folgerichtig und richtig dass wir dieses
Instrument auch nutzen um die
Unternehmen anders zu kapitalisieren und
die Versorgungssicherheit und die
Möglichkeit der Unternehmen weiter Gas
einzukaufen jetzt anders zu gewähren und
bereitzustellen
wenn ich bei Versorgungssicherheit bin
möchte ich nicht schließen ohne darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir nach wie vor in
einer kritischen Situation sind und die
Verbräuche runtergehen müssen bei der
bei dem Design der Gasanlage die ja
maßgeblich von der Kommission die
eingesetzt wurde von der Bundesregierung
vorgenommen werden soll muss darauf
geachtet werden dass die
spitzenverbräuche nicht subventioniert
werden dass die spitzenverbräuche
runtergehen wir sind immer noch an einer
kritischen Situation ja es ist zu wie
der Bundeskanzler gesagt hat die
Speicher sind voll aber wir sehen auch
dass die verbreche gerade im privaten
Bereich noch nicht in dem Maße
runtergehen wie es eigentlich notwendig
wäre deswegen bei aller Bereitschaft
jetzt viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen
und die Preise abzufedern die
Notwendigkeit Energie einzusparen bleibt
unvermindert bestehen vielen Dank
vielen Dank und als drittes im Bunde
ja meine Damen und Herren man kann es
nicht anders sagen wir befinden uns in
einem energiekrieg um Wohlstand und
Freiheit nach der Sabotage von noch
unbekannter Hand in der Ostsee hat sich
die Lage weiter verschärft wir können
jetzt nicht mehr davon ausgehen Gas aus
Russland zu beziehen dieser energiekrieg
hat zum Ziel
vieles von dem zu zerstören was die
Menschen sich persönlich über Jahrzehnte
aufgebaut haben was über Jahrzehnte an
Strukturen in Mittelstand Handwerk und
Industrie aufgebaut worden ist wir
können das nicht akzeptieren und werden
uns zur Wehr setzen
was wir heute vorstellen dass wir
erarbeitet haben dieser Beschluss das
ist eine glasklare Antwort an Putin aber
ist auch eine glasklare
Richtungsweisung an die Menschen in
unserem Land wir sind wirtschaftlich
stark und diese wirtschaftliche Stärke
mobilisieren wir wenn es erforderlich
ist so wie jetzt
wir haben einen Abwehrschirm gegen
diesen energiekrieg in wirtschaftlicher
Hinsicht beschlossen um die Folgen der
Knappheiten für die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher und die Wirtschaft
abzufedern und um Zeit zu gewinnen und
vorzubereiten auf eine neue Normalität
nach dieser Krise wir haben beraten auf
welchem Wege das gelingen kann ich habe
dazu den Bundeskanzler und den
Wirtschaftsminister die Reaktivierung
des Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds vorgeschlagen wir
werden Ihnen mit bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro in diesem Jahr befüllen oder anders
gesagt damit stehen bis zu 200
Milliarden Euro an Krisenintervention
zur Verfügung für die Zeit der Krise in
der voraussehbaren Zukunft 22 23 24 zum
Vergleich während der corona-pandemie
war der Wirtschaft stabilisierungsfond
mit 600 Milliarden befüllt worden und im
Jahr
2008 haben wir im Zuge der
bankenrettungspakete etwa 500 Milliarden
Euro gesehen also dieser Abwehrschirm
ist umfassend und wirksam er ist
zugleich aber gezielt auf diese Krise er
ist ein Schutz vor Existenzverlust aber
er soll selbst nicht die Inflation
befeuern und ausdrücklich folgen wir
nichts dem Beispiel Großbritanniens auf
den Weg einer expansiven
Fiskalpolitik aus diesem Grund wählen
wir ja das Instrument Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds mit einer klaren
gesetzlichen Zielbestimmung auf
Krisenbewältigung und aus diesem Grund
gilt für den Bundeshaushalt 2023 also
für die allgemeinen politischen Vorhaben
weiterhin die regelbremse der Schuld die
Regelgrenze der Schuldenbremse dazu
gleich noch Einsatz hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm warten Aufgaben vor uns wir
stellen den auf um mit finanziellen
Mitteln Zeit zu gewinnen um erstens
unsere Energieversorgung neu zu
programmieren also die Erneuerbaren wie
ich sie nenne freiheitsenergien an den
Start zu bringen auch durch
beschleunigte Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren wir geben jetzt
grünes Licht für Offshore Windenergie
wir nutzen für die Zeit der Krise hinter
diesem Abwehrschirm die Kohle bis 2024
wir haben auch jetzt beschrieben in dem
Papier was der Status Quo bei der
Kernenergie ist also zwei Süddeutsche
Kraftwerke auch im Frühjahr 2023 zu
verwenden das ist noch Gegenstand auch
der weiteren Beratung und
Meinungsbildung ist das worauf wir jetzt
schon bauen können sagt ganz offen ich
bin der Überzeugung wir brauchen alle
Kernkraftwerke auch bis 2024 das hat sie
auch nicht geändert wir werden
ausspeichern aus dem mit ihrem Geld
befüllten Gas speichern nicht alles aber
so viel um Marktsignale zu senden und
wir setzen auf europäische Lösungen also
das erste was wir tun hinter dem
Abwehrschirm ist unsere Energie und
Gasversorgung so aufstellen dass wir
über die Zeit und in ein neues normal
kommen das zweite wir erneuern und
stärker unsere Wirtschaft insgesamt wir
haben rekordinvestitionen im
Bundeshaushalt dabei bleibt es damit
erneuern wir von der digitalen bis zur
Schieneninfrastruktur unser Land und
investieren gezielt auch über den Klima-
und transformationsfonds in dauerhafte
Effizienzverbesserungen in dauerhafte
Stärkung der Wettbewerbsfähigkeit meine
Damen und Herren um diese Erneuerung und
Stärkung unserer Wirtschaft nicht zu
beeinträchtigen haben wir ein
belastungsmoratorium beschlossen während
der Zeit der Krise und während wir
diesen Abwehrschirm haben wird diese
Bundesregierung keine Maßnahmen
unterstützen oder auf den Weg bringen
die mit einem unverhält regelmäßigen
zusätzlichen Bürokratieaufwand für
Mittelstand Handwerk oder Industrie
verbunden sind in dieser Zeit der Krise
hinter dem Abwehrschirm muss sich die
Wirtschaft darauf konzentrieren können
sich vorzubereiten sich wieder zu
stärken Substanz zu erhalten wir wollen
sie nicht mit lästiger mit ärgerlicher
Bürokratie in dieser Zeit behelligen und
drittens abschließend hinter diesem
Abwehrschirm werden wir an den
Eckpunkten unserer Haushaltsplanung
Festhalten der Bundeshaushalt 2023 also
unter den Bedingungen der Schuldenbremse
ist völlig klar dass das nur geht wegen
des abwehrschirms aber auch viele
Unternehmen werden nur wegen des
abwehrschirms weiter im Markt
erfolgreich sein das gleiche gilt für
den Bundeshaushalt auch zu ohne den
Abwehrschirm wäre 2023 aus dem regulären
Haushalts natürlich eine gaspreisbremse
etwa nicht zu finanzieren aber wir
wollen eben klar Krisen Ausgaben trennen
von unserer regulären Haushaltsführung
sonst wäre es möglicherweise nicht
möglich auch darüber hinausgehende
Wünsche
zurückzuweisen durch diese Maßnahme
wollen wir ein ganz klares Signal an die
Kapitalmärkte senden auch wenn wir jetzt
einen solchen Abwehrschirm nutzen hält
Deutschland an seiner
stabilitätsorientierten an
Nachhaltigkeit interessierten
Finanzpolitik fest die deutschen
Staatsanleihen bleiben der Goldstandard
in der Welt darauf kann sich jeder
verlassen und auch die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger dürfen wissen dass wir weiter
sorgsam mit dem Geld der
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
umgehen jede zusätzliche Ausgabe auf
Kredit die wir jetzt leisten muss
zurückgezahlt muss mit zins- und Tilgung
bedient werden und würde dann die
Freiheit der künftigen
Generationen einschränken solide
Finanzpolitik ist also auch eine Form
der freiheitspolitik wenn uns das
damit dieses Paket jetzt rasch auf den
Weg zu bringen und den Ehrgeiz haben wir
dann wird dieser Abwehrschirm auch als
eine Art inflationsbremse wirken denn
wir dämpfen die Preisentwicklung wir
erhalten das Angebot und bauen Angebot
aus und zugleich gehen wir nicht in die
Richtung einer expansiven Finanzpolitik
noch mal der Vergleich zu Großbritannien
unser Ziel ist also ein Abwehrschirm
aufzubauen der zugleich neben dem
strukturerhalt auch einen wichtigen
Beitrag als inflationsbremse leistet
eine wirtschaftliche weitere
Verschlechterung der Lage abzuwenden
soweit vielen Dank die erste Frage hat
Andreas Rinke und ich habe weitere sechs
Fragesteller schon notiert Herr
Bundeskanzler ich hätte ganz gerne
gefragt ob denn in diesem Volumen die
ganzen Ausgabe Wünsche der Länder die ja
gestern beschlossen wurden alle schon
mit einberechnet sind oder droht ihnen
das am vierten Oktober wenn Sie mit den
Ländern verhandeln dann noch viele viele
Milliarden oben drauf kommen und der
Lindner eine ganz kurze Nachfrage
belastungsmoratorium was genau heißt es
heißt es dass da Projekte die im
Koalitionsvertrag
genannt werden mit Belastung für die
Wirtschaft jetzt erstmal zurückgestellt
werden
schönen Dank für Ihre Frage ich habe die
Beratung der Länder mit großer Interesse
verfolgt und freue mich schon auf die
Fortsetzung des Gesprächs dass wir jetzt
für nächste Woche vereinbart haben meine
Genesung macht auch solche Fortschritte
dass ich hoffen kann dass das
tatsächlich so stattfindet wie ich es
mir wünsche nämlich dass wir uns
persönlich begegnen jedenfalls hatte ich
heute schon den ersten negativen Test
und wenn das anhält dann kann ich ja
darauf hoffen dass die Quarantäne nicht
mehr lange anhält was die
sachgebende betrifft will ich aber gerne
sagen da sind doch sehr kluge
konstruktive Töne und Aussagen bei den
Ländern zu hören gewesen alle wissen
dass wir hier gemeinsam was machen
wollen und dass die Länder auch einen
großen Teil der Aufgaben schultern
müssen dazu habe ich die Bereitschaft
eigentlich von allen auch wahrgenommen
und natürlich ist es ein großes Datum
wenn jetzt der Bund mit 200 Milliarden
Euro der aus eigenen Krediten die er
selber Kredit finanziert dazu beiträgt
dass alle Lasten geringer werden die
Kosten für die Krankenhäuser die dort
neu bedrohtlich entstanden sind werden
geringer wenn die Energiekosten wieder
sinken das gilt für die sozialen
Einrichtungen für die Schulen für die
Universitäten das gilt
selbstverständlich auch für all das was
am Förderprogramm möglicherweise sonst
den Ländern notwendig wäre wenn der Hund
auf diese Art und Weise dafür sorgt dass
die Energiekosten sinken und die Sinken
der Inflation hilft dann ja auch ganz
konkret bei der Bewältigung der Aufgaben
den Ländern stehen insofern glaube ich
machen diese 200 Milliarden Euro doch
schon eine ganz erhebliche Veränderung
aus in Richtung einer gemeinsamen Tagung
der Lasten und der Anteil des Bundes ist
dann eben über die 50 Prozent die wir
knapp an dem bisherigen Paket zu
finanzieren haben hinaus noch dann die
ganze Summe von 200 Milliarden also ein
Vielfaches der Aufgaben die Länder und
Gemeinden stemmen insofern bin ich
sicher wir kommen zueinander
ja Herr Rinke also zunächst mal ist
einer der positivsten weiteren positiven
Nachrichten des heutigen Tages der
negative Test des Bundeskanzlers ich
glaube das ist jetzt ein guter Anlass
noch mal für das Präparat paxlovic zu
werben das habe ich nämlich während
meiner hotelgarantäne in Washington auch
bekommen und war bin fünf Tagen bei
mildem Verlauf
negativ also ich glaube das sollte in
Deutschland öfter genutzt werden wir
haben es ja auch dann hat der
Bundeskanzler völlig zu Recht gesagt
dass wir ja durch jetzt unseren Weg
Strom gaspreisbremse
stützmaßnahmen für Unternehmen
Ablösungen gasumlage und Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm im Wirtschafts- und
Stabilisierungsfonds ja auch die Länder
selbst Sportvereine und so weiter und so
fort entlasten und aus diesem Grund ja
auch vielleicht ein Entgegenkommen der
Länder jetzt willkommen wäre aus den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds selbst
wird es nicht möglich sein Forderungen
der Länder zu bedienen weil der an klar
umrissenen gesetzlichen Zweck bekommt
siehe unserer unserer Papier das ist ja
gerade die Idee Stichwort kein Dammbruch
das nur für eine umrissenen
krisenbegrenzenden Zweck finanziert
werden kann und bei der Frage
belastungsmoratorium will ich sie nur
auf den Text verweisen der heißt die
Krise führt bei vielen Unternehmen zu
zusätzlichen Belastungen es wird deshalb
sorgfältig darauf geachtet dass während
der Zeit der Krise keine
unverhältnismäßigen zusätzlichen
Bürokratielasten die Wirtschaft
beeinträchtigen in Klammern
belastungsmoratorium
als nächsten Fragenden den Kollegen der
neben Andreas Winkel sitzt
ja vielen Dank Daniel bukkaka ARD Herr
Bundeskanzler vor dem Hintergrund dass
die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt gesagt hat
zuletzt wurde im Vergleich zum
vergangenen Jahr 20 Prozent mehr
gasverbraucht möchte ich Sie fragen ist
das was sie jetzt vorlegen
gaspreisbremse zwar vielleicht zwar
populär aber vielleicht doch das falsche
Signal an die Leute und kommt von ihnen
vielleicht parallel auch noch sowas wie
ein verstärkter Appell oder sogar
Regelungen zum Energieeinsparen
in Appell hat ja der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bereits
formuliert eben wenige Minuten bevor Sie
Ihre Frage gestellt haben und das ist
unsere Haltung wir wissen dass wir alle
zusammen jetzt schon gucken müssen wie
wir möglichst viel Energie sparen wir
haben allerdings natürlich auch
gleichzeitig dafür gesorgt dass wir es
auch können ich habe bereits geschildert
was wir alles machen dazu zählt ja dass
wir
Kohlekraftwerke wieder in Betrieb nehmen
um statt mit Gas und Kohle Strom zu
produzieren dass wir sie auch nicht aus
dem Betrieb nehmen und den gleichen
Effekt zu erreichen dass wir die
Möglichkeit geschaffen um das in
Süddeutschland die beiden Atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen können das sind ja schon
auch erhebliche Sparmaßnahmen wir hatten
ohnehin eine große Maße Menge an
Gesetzen auf den Weg gebracht die es
Unternehmen ermöglichen dass sie
sparen was Gas betrifft indem sie auf
andere Energieträger umsteigen fühlt
sich genannt diese gesetzlichen
Erleichterung sind auf den Weg gebracht
und werden jetzt überall schon genutzt
wie ich sehe dass gibt viele
Entscheidungen die überall getroffen
werden und die auch dazu beitragen
können dass der gastverbrauch der
vorübergehend etwas Kritisches sinken
kann und das gleiche gilt dann natürlich
dafür dass wir mit
Nein noch mit gesteigerten Tempo alles
dafür tun dass wir auf die erneuerbaren
Energien setzen wir haben sehr sehr
viele Gesetze bereits auf den Weg
gebracht die dazu beitragen dass es
jetzt der Ausbau von offshore Windkraft
von Windkraftanlagen von Solarenergie
von Biomasse und auch unser Stromnetze
mit größerer Geschwindigkeit vorangehen
kann und das wird auch dazu beitragen
dass wir erheblich Energie einsparen
insofern ist das das was wir machen
zwei kurze Fragen wenn sie gestanden
Martin Greifer Hans bei die erste
richtet sich wahrscheinlich einen
Harbeck in ihrem Eckpunktepapier bleiben
sie noch etwas unkonkret was sie
ausgestattet und der gaspreisbremse
angeht der steht dann die Übernahme des
privaten Verbrauchs in Teilen gibt es
schon eine grobe Vorstellung welche
Größenordnung wieder gehen heute waren
wir kurz von 80% z.B die Rede des
Verbrauchs oder zweite Frage die sich
wahrscheinlich in den Lindner richtet
das ist ja durchaus ein gewagtes Manöver
was sie hier machen was ich ja wieder
ein frontloading machen wie schon beim
klimafond von 60 Milliarden jetzt gibt
es einen anderen Topf aber eine gleiche
Systematik da ist ja noch diese
Verfassungsklage der Union anhängig
haben sie noch mal durchgespielt dass
das was sie jetzt hier tun auf jeden
Fall verfassungsfest ist vielen Dank
die gasfest fremde muss zwei Ziele
gleichzeitig erreichen einmal die
Entlastung für Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher und für die Wirtschaft auf
den Gründen die jetzt mehrfach genannt
werden die Kernsubstanz der deutschen
Wirtschaft zu erhalten auch auf der
Nachfrage Seite wenn die
VerbraucherInnen die Verbraucher werden
dadurch ja auch entlastet also die
ökonomische und die soziale Balance in
Deutschland zu wahren und gleichzeitig
so klug programmiert sein oder
aufgestellt sein dass der Anreiz Energie
zu sparen Gas zu sparen erhalten bleibt
der Weg wird sein dass die gaskommission
die wir einen berufen haben dort
Vorschläge oder einen Vorschlag vorlegen
wird die sind auch mit Hochdruck an der
Arbeit und ich finde es ausdrücklich
richtig und klug diesen Weg zu gehen
weil dort ja ein breites Expertengremium
zusammenkommt wo dann
Verbraucherschützerin
Verbraucherschützer aber auch
Unternehmen und
Industrievertreter an einem Tisch sitzen
die dann die verschiedenen
kommunizierenden Röhren jeweils aus
ihrer Sicht beitragen können und
ich die gasversion hat ja eigentlich ein
bisschen mehr Zeit auch um ganz andere
und sehr komplexe Fragen beispielsweise
der Marktordnung jetzt für uns große
Anteile der deutschen Gasversorger quasi
staatlich
verantwortet sind neu zu denken also was
machen wir eigentlich mit den
Unternehmen das sind ja auch Fragen aber
die sind nicht so dringlich wie die
Frage wie sieht die gaspreisbremse im
konkreten aus deswegen da bin ich aber
auch gute Hoffnung dass das gelingt
denke ich dass die Vorschläge dazu
zeitnah als eigentlich erwartet
vorgestellt werden und dann werden wir
die beraten und nach kurzer
beratungsfrist schnell umsetzen
ergreife das
Verfahren ist nicht riskant denn die
bisherige Klage der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist ja schon
unbegründet
das war beim zweiten Nachtrag 2021 ganz
klarer
Veranlassungszusammenhang in der
corona-pandemie nicht erfolgte
Investitionen nachholen zu können über
den Klima und transformationsfonds
vorliegend ist der
Veranlassungszusammenhang ebenfalls
vollkommen eindeutig ein Angriffskrieg
Russlands auf die Ukraine in Verbindung
mit einem energiekrieg Deutschlands
es war jetzt erforderlich politisch
kommunikativ und haushaltspolitisch
klarzumachen dass das nötige Volumen für
diesen Abwehrschirm zur Verfügung steht
in anderen setzen gesagt Deutschland
zeigt hier seine wirtschaftliche
Schlagkraft in einem energiekrieg und
deshalb musste jetzt auch diese Größe
von bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro man wird
ja sehen welches Volumen am Ende
benötigt worden sein wird das auch zu
zeigen und der Veranlassungszusammenhang
ist noch eindeutiger in einer solchen
Situation wie wir sie jetzt haben
erwarte ich auch dass die cdu/csu
Bundestagsfraktion im Prinzip diesem
Vorgehen zustimmt denn Teile der
Maßnahmen die wir jetzt umsetzen sind ja
selbst von dort auch vorgeschlagen
worden freilich ohne jeden
Finanzierungsvorschlag
als nächstes auf der Liste Gerald drauf
wenn er vom Spiegel
wir haben Herr Scholz bereuen Sie dass
sie nicht schon am 22 juli bei ihrer
Pressekonferenz diesen großen Wurf
gemacht haben und damit dann riskiert
haben dass über den Sommer und jetzt
auch bisschen den Herbst hinein eine
große Debatte in Brandt ist und ja
vielleicht diese Frage erstmal
vielen Dank für Ihre Frage wir haben
zunächst ein Problem gelöst hat
lösen müssen das zu tun hatte damit dass
ein Teil der Lieferung aus Russland
nicht mehr Erfolg ist und deshalb
Unternehmen in großen Schwierigkeiten
gereibten sind die Lieferverträge hatten
die sie nicht mehr bedienen konnten weil
das Gas das sie weiter verkaufen wollten
nicht mehr geliefert wurde und sie alles
neu zu hören Preisen einkaufen dann aber
weitergeben mussten zu den geringeren
vereinbarten Preisen wir werden also
alle nicht in Lage gewesen diese
Situation zu überleben jetzt sehen wir
dass es gar keine Gaslieferung mehr gibt
das ist ja nun seit einiger Zeit
unübersehbar und Gott sei Dank haben wir
uns genau darauf vorbereitet und deshalb
haben wir auch sehr früh in richtiger
Abfolge die notwendigen Entscheidungen
getroffen zum Beispiel die
gastkommission die uns jetzt mit Oktober
wahrscheinlich sehr sehr schnell wir
haben jetzt ja Ende September das wird
nicht viele Tage dauern ein Vorschlag
mal zur Umsetzung der gaspreisbremse
diese Gast diese gastkommission haben
wir ja schon als Regierung vor einiger
Zeit auf den Weg gebracht und
beschlossen dass sie Tagen soll und ihre
Arbeit machen soll als wir das dritte
große Entlastungspaket von nochmal 65
Milliarden Euro auf den Weg gebracht
hatten und das war klar für uns dass bei
dieser Gelegenheit natürlich die
Regierung die Kommission auch in die
Lage versetzen muss dass sie weiß wie
viel Geld sie denn einsetzen kann und ob
wir das Geld mobilisieren dass dazu
notwendig ist deshalb haben wir sehr
systematisch darauf hingearbeitet
rechtzeitig zu Beginn der Beratung eine
solche Aussage machen zu können und
genau das tun wir insofern ist das jetzt
hier ein sehr weitreichender ein sehr
dramatischer Schritt der aber genau der
richtige ist in dieser Situation und
wenn ich den Überblick vom Ergebnis darf
unsere drei entlastungspakete haben
zusammen fast 100 Milliarden mit vielen
entlastungsbürgern und Bürger der
Verbesserung des Wohngeldes zum Beispiel
der neue Konstruktion des Bürgergeldes
mit
erhöhten Kindergeld das Bezahlen mit
Steuerentlastung für viele Bürgerinnen
und Bürger der Möglichkeit die
Rentenbeiträge vom steuerpflichtigen
Einkommen abzuziehen also vielen vielen
Entlastung die bei vielen auf
unterschiedliche Weise ankommen und dazu
kommen jetzt noch mal diese 200
Milliarden also das ist eine
entlastungsschritt von 300 Milliarden
der uns in diesen und den nächsten
Jahren helfen wird durch diese
große schwere Zeit zu kommen aber wir
werden durchkommen weil Deutschland die
wirtschaftliche Kraft hat und den
sozialen Zusammenhalt als soziale
Demokratie der notwendig ist damit man
so eine Herausforderung bewältigen kann
als nächstes
ja Michael bauchmelder sind deutsche
Zeitung eine Frage an Minister Habeck
die gasumlage soll ja am Samstag
eigentlich in Kraft treten was genau
passiert ja jetzt wird die Verordnung
aufgehoben und was geschieht dann mit
jedem gastkunden die schon in Hinblick
auf die Umlage jetzt Preiserhöhungen im
Briefkasten hatten und das wird aus dem
Mehrwertsteuersenkung die auch mit Blick
auf die gasumlage
verabredet wurde dann
die Gasanlage ist perverordnung
eingesetzt worden und wird per
Verordnung zurückgezogen werden das
Umlaufverfahren ist eine
Ressortabstimmung im Kabinett ist
eingeleitet also mit Beginn dieser
Pressekonferenz ist diese
ressortbeteiligung eingeleitet werden
eingeleitet worden kurze Frist die
Gasanlage wird also jetzt vom in die
Annalen der Geschichte eingehen
die sollte es die gilt ja ab erstens
hinten sollte es schon Abzüge geben was
zu überprüfen wäre müssen die
zurückgezahlt werden das dauert dann
vielleicht ein bisschen aber eigentlich
gilt sie am ersten zehnten und deswegen
sind zwar die Briefe gedruckt aber
sehr viel Geld wenn überhaupt kann dann
auch nicht abgezogen worden sein sonst
muss es zurückgezahlt werden die
gasumlage wird nicht mehr benötigt das
haben der Bundeskanzler Christian
Lindner und ich eben ausgeführt weil wir
ein alternatives Finanzinstrument
geschaffen haben wichtig ist
die Gasanlage da mache ich ja kein
Geheimnis daraus zwar nie ein populäres
Instrument als wir das vorgestellt haben
haben wir immer gesagt das ist eine
schlechte eine
drückende Botschaft die verkündet wird
aber gleichwohl eine notwendige
Botschaft weil ja so wie Olaf Scholz ist
eben gerade dargestellt hat ein Verlust
permanent entsteht im hoher
Milliardenhöhe ohne dass er ausgeglichen
werden kann und dieses Delta musste
geschlossen werden sonst konnten die
Unternehmen ihre wirtschaftliche
Tätigkeit also die Versorgungssicherheit
Einkauf und Weitergabe von Gas nicht
mehr aufrechterhalten jetzt gibt es
einen besseren Weg einen anderen Weg der
vor ein paar Wochen noch nicht zur
Verfügung stand der ist die
Kapitalisierung der Unternehmen über den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds aus
diesem Volumen von 200 Milliarden Euro
deswegen wird sie nicht mehr benötigt
und wird eben per Verordnung
zurückgezogen werden
oder ist dabei zurückgezogen zu werden
die Mehrwertsteuersenkung allerdings
bleibt und bleibt erhalten und wird auch
aus die auf die fernwärmeverträge
übertragen werden als weitere Maßnahmen
mit der Entlastung in dieser Zeit wo die
Energiepreise für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger so hoch sind
dann habe ich kein Einstein
ARD einmal gerne noch als Nachfrage
diese Mehrwertsteuersenkung und die
Kosten die damit einhergehen sind die in
diesen 200 Milliarden enthalten oder
kommen die sie schütteln schon den Kopf
die kommen noch on top dann noch eine
Frage an Sie Herrn Bundeskanzler Scholz
es wurde ja jetzt doch auch auf dem
Podium wieder deutlich dass es bei einem
anderen Energiethema weiterhin ein sehr
sichtbaren Dissens in ihrer
Bundesregierung gibt beim Thema
Atomkraftwerke Herr Lindner hat gerade
noch mal ausgeführt dass seiner Meinung
nach die Atomkraftwerke bis 2024 laufen
müssen
wann wird es da eine Entscheidung
innerhalb der Bundesregierung geben die
Klarheit darüber
schafft wie es denn bei dem Thema
weitergeht
beim nächsten Mal haben wir ein
Gesetzentwurf auf den Brief gebracht der
den weiteren Betrieb diese
Atomkraftwerke Anfang des Jahres
ermöglicht und das ist glaube ich die
wichtige Botschaft für diesen Winter und
ansonsten ist es ja klar dass
unterschiedliche Vorstellungen und den
Parteien zu dieser Frage diskutiert
worden sind das Wichtigste aus meiner
Sicht ist das die Entscheidung für
diesen Winter auf alle Fälle getroffen
werden und wir die Möglichkeit haben
diese Atomkraftwerke zu nutzen
einen weiteren Frage bedarf insofern
bedanke ich mich für ihr Kommen halt
Andreas Rinke einer allerletzte vor
alles aufbricht
offenbar ich weiß nicht ob die Frage
jetzt geht ehrlich gesagt nehmen wir
einen Lindner und Herrn Harbeck wie
lange gelten denn die Maßnahmen die
jetzt beschlossen sind also ohne
Abschlussdatum oder sind die Maßnahmen
die sie jetzt beschlossen haben
terminiert
sie meinen das heute vorgestellte 2 der
Abwehrschirm die 200 Milliarden die sind
auf die Krise bezogen und nach den
Rechnungen die wir immer haben dann bis
Ende Winter 24 also März oder April 24
alles klar bis zu 200 Milliarden gesagt
um sehr auskömmliches Volumen eben zu
beschreiben je besser die Maßnahmen zur
Senkung der Gaspreise und der
Strompreise funktionieren Kraft Natur
der Sache weniger Volumen wird benötigt
auch auf europäischer Ebene Robert nur
du bist morgen bei energierat wird ja
über Maßnahmen nachgedacht die würden
natürlich das was wir an Finanzvolumen
national mobilisieren reduzieren oder
der Finanzminister sich auch sehr freuen
dann ist auch dieser Appell angekommen
danke
das Geld geht weg und das ist im
Gasbereich völlig klar ich meine die
Unternehmen brechen uns hier weg wir
machen mit viel Steuergeld oder jetzt
Kreditaufnahme das muss ja auch
irgendwann zurückgezahlt werden eine
hilfs Operation und dann anderen Stellen
sammelt sich das Geld so und darüber
wird zu reden sein müssen das ist ja
klar dass wir volkswirtschaftliches
Vermögen gerade ins Ausland
transferieren aus der Not heraus aber
diese Not
sollte jedenfalls bei den Partnerländern
den befreundeten Ländern eben auch
gesehen werden und nicht ausgenutzt
werden
okay dann bedanke ich mich sehr schließe
diese Pressekonferenz und bedanke mich
für euch gasumlage geht in die Analen
der Geschichte ein sagt
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck das war live
aus dem Kanzleramt die Pressekonferenz
mit dem Bundeskanzler sowie den
Ministern für Wirtschaft und Finanzen
der Kanzler sag